I need know what do anybody it my dream
has always been to work with computers
as a kid I used to ask questions like
who invented the computer or who created
this game these young people live at the
Zaatari refugee camp in Jordan it's one
of the world's largest camps I'm honest
17 and comes from Syria he's been here
for two years he's teaching other young
refugees computer animation he learned
it himself at a similar course in the
spring this is part of refugee code week
where refugees teach other refugees IT
skills
it's a program sponsored by the United
Nations refugee agency UNHCR and German
software firm ASAP in all 10,000
youngsters across the Middle East took
part in 2016 I'm drawing pictures of
girls and balls and cats and I'm making
the move or jump or dance or run we have
a lot of fun here
the most promising students get to join
the 16 week intensive coding boot camp I
men may have more experience than the
others here but he still wants to learn
more he's ready to take the intensive
course there are a few opportunities to
get a job here in the refugee camp but
if you become a programmer you can be
recruited and get a job outside the camp
able to leave and travel and see the
whole world God willing um eighty
thousand Syrian refugees live at za'tari
here in the middle of the Jordanian
desert the sprawling refugee camp has
become a town of its own there are
schools here market squares and even a
local payment system what the people
here don't have is any idea what the
future might hold for them
young people are in urgent need of
education and training the refugee code
week has two goals addressed the
literacy the education among the refugee
population but also the employability of
this young talent those young refugees
where they are empowered with
job-related skills and then they can
benefit from jobs at s AP or business
partners and ecosystem it takes a
quarter of an hour to drive across the
camp we're going to visit a man and his
family in their corrugated metal
container
I'm am and his family fled their home in
the Syrian province of Dura in January
2013 when the Civil War got dangerously
close for a year they moved around
within Syria before they crossed into
Jordan over there we lived in homes with
electricity and water we got everything
we needed and we even had a car and we
didn't need to rent everything
thank God we found safety here we're
grateful to Jordan for taking us in and
giving us shelter
they are now just a hundred kilometers
from their old home in Syria when the
bombs fall there they say they can hear
the explosions the Jordanian capital
Amman is an hour's drive from the camp
is there any need for young people with
IT skills we went to find out ali al
Hilli is from iraq and came here a
decade ago
he develops game apps for the arab
market
he knows the IT scene here well and
organizes meetings for start-up
entrepreneurs from across the region a
man is being transformed into a moral IT
city a lot of applications are now in
the mobile applications are now
presented to order your food gas taxi
online so that a lot of companies in
here are moving toward the mobile
devices and that movement
would need a lot of folders so that we
can cover the shortage in the market
Oasis 500 is a seed investment company
and Business Accelerator for high-tech
and creative startups it's become an
influential player in the Middle East
here Ali al Hilli introduces us to
Syrian entrepreneur Salim Najjar he fled
Syria four years ago last month he set
up his own online retail business
selling home decorations refugee
entrepreneurs are quite a rarity Jordan
doesn't often grant work permits to
refugees many of those who have a job
work freelance for foreign companies
Salim Najjar says foreign IT firms don't
ask for official working papers it's the
skills that count being a refugee you
need to survive and I believe that if
I'm I don't have programming skills I
won't be able to find a good job I won't
be able to get a high salary to pay the
rent for my family to support my family
because I don't know anyone here before
I came I didn't know anyone and I had to
establish a new life after I lost
everything in Syria starting a new life
is what most refugees at the Zaatari
camp can only hope for at the moment
[Music]
iemon doesn't think you'll be going home
to syria anytime soon Inessa horny Aisha
11 km behind us right now I'm going to
stay here in the refugee camp and
continue learning until I master
programming languages when I leave this
camp armed with that knowledge the
coding course will help me prepare for a
job and create a future for myself
God willing civil war at homes stole the
future i man once had now he's getting a
second chance here in Jordan
[Music]